Hunter Biden's tax problems business
dealings and well-known drug and alcohol
addiction have created a political
headache for his father President Joe
Biden Hunter by Connor Biden now the
president's son has pleaded not guilty
to felony Firearms charges an unexpected
twist after a previous deal he had
reached to avoid those charges suddenly
collapsed he clearly thought he was
going to put this behind him and it
wouldn't really be an issue during his
father's reelection campaign but that
went up in smoke here's what you need to
know about Hunter Biden's legal troubles
that could potentially set the stage for
another high-profile criminal trial
during the 2024 election season
a Yale and Georgetown educated lawyer
Hunter Biden is the second son of
President Biden he never worked in
government but he was a lawyer in the
Washington sense where he was partly
lobbying partly advising clients and
making a lot more money than either his
father or his brother at the time in
2014 Hunter Biden was paid fifty
thousand dollars per month to sit on the
board of barisma a Ukrainian Energy
company run by an oligarch seeking
closer ties to Washington at the time
his father is Vice President he also has
Ukraine as a part of his portfolio he's
working on this campaign to sort of help
Ukraine root out corruption so that ends
up presenting some qualms for people in
the administration and then ends up
presenting a lot more problems for
Hunter Biden down the line did you and
your father ever discuss Ukraine no as I
said the only time was after a news
account and it wasn't a discussion in
any way there's no but to this no both
Joe and Hunter Biden have denied any
wrongdoing related to barisma Hunter
Biden said he displayed poor judgment in
accepting the board seat
the younger Biden continued to pursue
his foreign business ties once his
father exited the vice presidency a
spokesman for his legal team has said
Hunter Biden was a private citizen with
every right to pursue his own business
endeavors
those dealings coincided with challenges
in Hunter Biden's personal life
including the death of his older brother
Beau Biden in 2015.
so hunter's life takes a quite a
dramatic turn he very openly talks about
how he sort of descended into alcohol
and drug addiction he was addicted to
crack cocaine his his marriage splits up
so his life is is really rapidly
deteriorating hi Joseph Robinette Biden
Jr do solemnly swear just before Joe
Biden was set to assume the presidency
in 2021 Hunter Biden revealed he was
under criminal investigation a probe
that began in 2018 and was being led by
Trump appointed U.S attorney David Weiss
according to court documents filed in
June Federal prosecutors in Delaware say
hunter Biden received more than 1.5
million dollars in annual income in both
2017 and 2018 and failed to pay taxes on
it despite owing more than a hundred
thousand dollars each year during the
investigation an associate of Hunter
Biden covered the 1.9 million dollars
that he owed in back taxes for those
years including interest and penalties
the charges extended Beyond his finances
in a separate filing prosecutors say
hunter Biden knowingly possessed a
firearm in October 2018 despite being
addicted to drugs and barred from owning
a gun
from our reporting we do know that in
2022 they did start having a lot of
witnesses come before the grand jury and
at that point it seemed like they were
you know moving towards a potential case
ultimately you know earlier this year
they tried to reach a deal hunter Biden
agreed to plead guilty to two
misdemeanor tax charges under the deal
the younger Biden would also have to
undergo a pre-trial diversion program
that would allow him to avoid gun
charges in exchange for staying sober
and not getting another gun usually you
think like they'd both understand what
they've agreed to and the judge is going
to sign off on it and everyone's gonna
you know move on that's not what
happened in July
in a stunning turnaround the plea deal
imploded after a U.S district judge said
she needed more information before
signing off
both sides weren't on the same page
about what exactly was covered by this
deal hunter thought you know this
essentially ended the investigation and
the government was saying like no we are
going to continue our investigation and
we can't promise that there's no other
charges I'm here today to announce the
appointment of David Weiss as a special
counsel consistent with the Department
of Justice regulations governing such
matters with the plea deal in shambles
Federal prosecutors indicted Hunter
Biden on September 14th on three gun
crimes claiming he knowingly lied on a
disclosure form when he bought and
possessed a gun while addicted to drugs
on October 3rd Hunter Biden pleaded not
guilty to the gun charges prosecutors
did not bring tax charges against him
although they could still do so
a potential trial of Hunter Biden could
deepen his legal problems as Republicans
pushed to implicate the president in his
son's business activities welcome back
everyone I am directing our house
committee to open a formal impeachment
inquiry into President Joe Biden
this logical Next Step will give our
committees the full power to gather all
the facts
and answers for the American public
the White House said the president
wasn't a party to his son's business
Affairs and has done nothing wrong in a
statement Hunter Biden's legal team said
Republicans have been chasing and
failing to prove their own conspiracies
about Hunter Biden and his legitimate
business activities it does set up the
potential for you know a trial on his
sort of messy personal life and business
life almost at the same time that you
know his father is running for
reelection and his father's rival for
the presidency potentially former
president Trump is also facing his own
trials on criminal charges and so that
is a very real potential and that's
pretty unprecedented in a you know
American history